if you think about what is the greatest
case study in the world ever right and
we rank the top 10 greatest case studies
there's a lot of them right what case
studies could be but one of the greatest
case studies in the world is how this
you know group of 50-something men came
together who were not happy about what
was going on in Britain and they started
this idea in 1776 and they wrote out the
Federalist Paper the Constitution you
know etc etc
and then that went and turned into this
behemoth
of a country that positively impacted
the world technology that's being used
around the world and it validated that
the best economical system in the world
is capitalism
um
if it allowed people to go out there and
are willing to work and how big of a
dream they wanted to build and how big
of a life they wanted to build you kind
of leave them alone you know if they put
a limit on how big of a YouTube channel
you could make you can't have a YouTube
channel over 10 million I mean you know
you wouldn't have PewDiePie you wouldn't
have Mr Beast maybe you'd be happy if
you didn't have these guys I'm not too
familiar with those guys but let me just
say this though but if what you were
saying was true right I mean if we were
real but it is going to base it well it
is I mean this is the greatest case
study ever well but if you really want
to look into actual I mean if you're
really looking at that case study right
you got to say
um this country and you know
it is what it is but the idea uh that
this country was just simply capitalism
it was also it was a tremendous amount
of free labor that was used to harvest a
crop that made Northerners wealthy
Northern financier is wealthy shipping
magnets wealthy
um and it made obviously the plantation
owners wealthy now we would never
Advocate that you should have slavery
today of course we wouldn't but but but
so to go back but wait wait a minute
wait a minute you can't say something
like that and give the black guy to the
country because that was done in
practically every country in the world
so it was a very but here's the part I
don't want to I don't want to debate the
the this is this is what I would say was
slavery unique no no no versus anyone no
the point the point I'm trying to make
to you is if that was accessible
everywhere okay well no it wasn't in
most countries they had a form of
slavery at one point also didn't have
the confluation between slavery cheap
labor and the fertile ground to grow
cotton for instance for instance let me
just give you another example of like of
this because you really if you if you're
gonna to talk about American history and
I'm not this is not about America is
particularly uniquely evil because their
slavery was uniquely worse than someone
else you know granted we had chattel
slavery which was not as necessarily
popular or other places but that doesn't
matter the bottom line is if you're
going to make an assessment on how this
country grew
put aside like you know the the feelings
of ego or hurt feelings that it makes me
feel bad as an American whatnot if you
want to just look at it coldly all right
you look at something like the Trail of
Tears the reason why we have the Trail
of Tears and killed all of those uh
Native American people is because
plantation owners in Georgia and Alabama
wanted the fertile ground that had been
given uh to those uh native tribes
because it was fertile ground they could
grow more cotton there when when we
basically eliminated those Native
Americans sent them on the Trail of
Tears
the number of slaves grew exponentially
because these plantation owners got this
raw material which was the fertile
ground they brought in Free Labor to uh
to harvest it the hardest part of of
cotton uh of dealing with cotton is the
harvesting of it I mean this is part of
the system and you know I'm not saying
that America is uniquely evil because it
or unique
you're saying that I'm not saying I'm
saying that I'm just looking at the I'm
saying the greatest case study Patrick
I'm just looking at the cold hard facts
and if you're going to look at it as a
case study how do you have to make that
assessment how do you do it that is part
of it how do you free labor business how
do you judge a great idea succeeding how
do you judge a great idea succeeding
what's your way of judging a great idea
what's my way of how do you like let's
just say we come up with an idea okay
and by the way the idea could be as
small as hey moving forward Sam I think
what we need to do with your YouTube
channel what's the goal
uh what do you mean what's the goal well
if I'm going to measure a great idea I
want to know what the goal is because I
feel like here's the thing no no no and
I don't mean this I mean this with all
due respect yeah but I feel like your
assessment of a of of a great idea or of
a great thing of this is measured in how
many dollars no I never said that I
never said that no I'm not all of your
examples can you play along instead of
assuming just play along instead of
assuming and jump into conclusion I'm
going to give you the respect give me to
respect as well how do we judge agree
how do you judge a great father
how do I judge a great father yeah how
do you say he's a good are you a good
father I I try to be okay I try to be so
I don't know if I am I don't know if I
am quite frankly you and I are not going
to know if we're good Fathers I think
for another 30 years you know we'll find
out if we're a good father well what
would be the measure like if you want it
like like what is the metrics in which
you imagine no problem so so let me let
me ask you this way okay to me uh how do
we judge a great show on YouTube how do
we judge a great restaurant how do you
judge a great uh I don't know a great
movie how do we judge a uh a great party
how do we judge a great nightclub how do
we how do we judge any of those I wanna
this is what I would love to do this you
write down how you judge a great show on
YouTube and I write down how I I judge a
great uh show on YouTube and and you
know restaurant movie and I guarantee
it's going to be different oh oh okay so
how do you judge a great restaurant I
mean I I great restaurant I'm not so
great when it comes to food but I would
say like a great movie for me is uh is a
function of like maybe how much emotion
I feel or how many insights I get from
it
um and are they doing something that
impacts the the the cultural language of
film I mean that's the way I would joke
okay so I would say one of the best ways
to judge how what country has done it
the best around the world is how many
people can't wait to go there and if you
judge it based on that America's kicking
everybody's tail I'm an Iranian guy I'm
from Iran you look at the amount of
immigration I went through a refugee
camp to come here dude my parents got a
divorce my mom's in town last night or
now we're having a conversation until
late at night we sacrificed a lot they
sacrificed their marriage language
barrier all just to come to America okay
my mom and dad never said what was the
situation in Iran
a pretty shitty situation in Iran but
also why did well we had a lot of others
I'm in Honduras we had 100 but we had
195 other options why do we come here
why don't we go to Russia why don't we
go to China why don't we go to Venezuela
why don't we go to Cuba why don't we go
to Germany why do we come to America why
is America leading 4X number two 40 plus
million people that want to come here so
you could say well you know it's because
that's not really a right way to measure
it because if you think about this this
that why do so many people want to come
to America I think I think there I I
mean I I think because there is a a
promise
I don't know if it's kept many instances
is not but there's a promise of more
Economic Opportunity certainly depending
on where you come from it's it's it's
pretty clear like I mean if you're
coming from Honduras
um there's an uh there's there's more
Economic Opportunity it's also
theoretically safer right than than
Honduras is many of those people also
have relatives that come here I mean
there's a whole host of reasons you've
got also a um a tremendous mix of people
here so there's a community there's an
Iranian Community why are they coming
here though well why did they come here
because it's a lot easier drive to
Russia than it is to drive to U.S I
can't even drive to you it's a longer
flight well I think it's expensive
democracy too got it so because of what
the founders created a system where I
could come here as an atheist when I
came here I was an atheist I didn't
believe in a God that I didn't think God
exists if a god really exists why would
we have all these wars in Iran that
makes no sense to me good for you weak
people that you think you need to go to
I don't need it and then later on in
life at 25 years old I made a different
decision but nobody judged me if I was
an atheist when I was in the Army nobody
said anything to me I yeah no but I was
I was Iranian I went in the Army yeah we
had some jokes we made fun of each other
truly like people made fun of each other
but we got along I feel like you
misinterpreted why I was explaining that
the the uh how the the economic power
was built in this country I'm not saying
that America is bad that's not my point
are you saying this is the greatest case
study of a country in the world ever
with the greatest case study yeah
meaning meaning meaning that that when
it comes down to show an opportunity no
other country has done it better than
America as based on what it was founded
on I mean you could argue that like you
know the our Mobility numbers certainly
at times at times
that's why I want to go back to that
that's right because the time where we
had the most mobility in our society now
granted we still you know in the 50s and
60s if you were black you didn't have
the same civil rights obviously uh I
mean you know you couldn't engage in
Commerce in the same way you couldn't
you know uh
country's always going to make progress
we keep getting better it sounds like
you want to make America great again but
just tax purposes
when I go to the when I when I think
about the the the the the greatest
expansion of the economy for the most
amount of people it was during that era
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]